today on the Matt Walsh show the ancient
communist Bernie Sanders has finally
dropped out of the race he says that he
won the ideological struggle which is
clearly not the case because he's the
guy who dropped out but will his
ideology prevail in the future is the
question and here's something I'm
thinking about these shutdowns that were
happened that are happening right now
will they ultimately move us towards
becoming a more socialist country or
could it have the opposite effects we'll
talk about that also five headlines
including the new unemployment numbers
which are ghastly and today it brings me
no pleasure especially this week of all
weeks but I must cancel the Pope and
I'll explain why all of that coming up
but so we begin with this of course
Bernie Sanders as I said dropping out of
the race of course he did that only
after the Wisconsin primaries which were
on Monday I think and people waited in
line for hours in the middle of a
pandemic Bernie Sanders could have
spared them that but he decided because
it's not like the the it's not like the
results of the Wisconsin primary
mattered anyway in terms of his chances
so he could have spared them that
decided not to because it needed one
last ego trip but he dropped out
yesterday finally did a live stream
announcing his decision and his campaign
and here's because I'm a masochist I'm
gonna for some reason play a little bit
of it listen to this if we don't believe
that we are entitled to health care as a
human right we will never achieve
universal health care if we don't
believe that we are entitled to decent
wages and working conditions
millions of us will continue to live in
poverty if we don't believe that we are
entitled to all of the education we
require to fulfill our dreams many of us
will leave school saddled with huge debt
or never get the education we need if we
don't believe that we are entitled to
live in a world that has a clean
environment and it's not ravaged by
climate change we will continue to see
more droughts floods rising sea levels
and increasingly uninhabitable planet
if we don't believe that we are entitled
to live in a world of justice democracy
adventists without racism sexism
homophobia xenophobia or religious
bigotry we will continue to have massive
income and wealth inequality prejudice
and hatred mass incarceration terrified
immigrants and hundreds of thousands of
Americans sleeping out on the streets in
the richest country on earth and
focusing on that new vision for America
is what our campaign has been about and
what in fact we have accomplished few
would deny that over the course of the
past five years our movement has won the
ideological struggle so I wanted to play
that part of his of his spiel because it
perfectly encapsulates Bernie Sanders
utopian deluded narcissistic incoherent
why should merely believing that we're
entitled to something make that thing
happen this is the logic of Peter Pan
this is the logic of an r kelly song i
believe i can fly this is not serious
thought these are not serious ideas and
then he says at the end there that he
won the ideological struggle which it's
it's a little bit like a guy who just
lost one-on-one basketball saying well I
I won the athletic struggle and that's
precisely what you didn't do that's
exactly what happened here is you what
happened here is you losing the athletic
struggle so this is it that the exact
opposite is the case
still he did reveal or help to reveal or
he is maybe I would is better to say
he's a symptom of a very dangerous
ideological trend in our country so
there is a you didn't win the struggle
his idea his ideology is not prevailing
obviously but there is a trend and it is
trending in that direction and it's a
trend that skews young a trend towards
socialism a trend towards dependence
entitlement government control and it's
especially tragic and concerning to see
this among young people concerning
because young people are the future the
few the future generation now it's it's
possible I guess we
could hope that young people and when I
say young people I'm talking about my
own generation those young
whippersnappers it's possible they could
grow up as they get older and grow out
of this socialism thing or not but it's
it's tragic because especially when
you're young you know to be a young
person begging for the government's
assistance being helpless being you know
acting like you're so vulnerable and you
need the government to come in and solve
all your problems
that's I don't think there's ever a
point your life where you should have
that attitude but especially not when
you're young when you're young and
particularly if you're young and you're
not married you don't have a family a
lot of Bernie Sanders supporters they're
in college or they're just out of
college they have no real
responsibilities in life they have
nobody depending on them this is the
time to be independent and to enter
crave independence and to go out and and
take risks I mean healthy risks not like
I don't mean I don't mean try different
drugs type of risks I mean taking risks
with trying trying different things
different career paths figuring out what
you're what you're good at what your
passions are you know you move across
the country somewhere and you try a job
if it doesn't work out it's not a big
deal you can just go work somewhere else
it's really it's really there's there's
not a lot now of course these days you
can't actually do that but once all this
is over so that's that's what youth is
supposed to be all about it supposed to
be about sort of a radical independence
and to see the opposite trend these days
is is pretty tragic but I have to wonder
speaking of entitlement and socialism
what impact will recent events have on
the ideological struggle that bernie is
talking about because I could see this
going one of two ways there's the
optimistic version and then there's the
pessimistic version and you probably
already guess which one I'm leaning
towards here but let's start with the
optimistic version
perhaps Americans will see the
government obliterating the economy as
it has been doing
and assuming near total control over
their lives and they will experience
this let's say sampling of communism
this is like like someone at the grocery
store handing out samples of meatballs
which by the way another tragedy here
another another casualty of the corona
virus epidemic is probably that free
samples at the grocery store we're never
gonna see those again which is which is
really terrible but in any case so this
this is this is sort of like a free
sample of communism that's being handed
out to us and maybe optimistically
people experience this free sample of
communism and they revolt against it
maybe they see what it's like to be
entirely dependent on the government to
be controlled to live without freedom
and we as Americans say enough of this
never again this is not what I want this
is not how I want to live and then this
whole experience leads to a great
reawakening of American culture and we
experience again a thirst for
independence and freedom that's the
optimistic possibility and by the way
that that's that's the only hope we have
that's if there's any way of coming back
from this especially when we look at
what the government has done to society
and the economy if there's any hope of
us clawing our way back from this it's
going to have to be through this we
would need a massive cultural
reawakening so that's that's one
possibility I don't find it terribly
convincing I'm afraid to say the
pessimistic the negative version is that
the government by wiping out millions of
jobs and in just a second we'll talk
about how many jobs they've wiped out so
far
but the government by waihi up millions
of jobs is breeding dependence forcing
people to be dependent on it through no
fault of their own so if you had your
job taken away by the government and now
you're you're depending on the check
they're sending which won't be nearly
enough for most people but it's it's
it's you still need it though now in
that case
of course it's not your fault it's the
government's fault and that's why I even
have people send me email so talking
about the ethical what if I get sent a
check from the government and you know I
don't want to I I don't believe in
taking that kind of help from the
government what do I do
well you cashed the check you should you
should have no feel no guilt about that
whatsoever this is this right now is not
welfare you actually are entitled to
that money because the government has
taken your job from you and told you you
can't work and support your family they
do owe you compensation so you actually
are entitled to that it's it's an
entitlement in the literal sense of the
word the problem with most entitlements
is that the people who are getting the
entitlement aren't actually entitled to
what they're getting in this case you
are entitled to it so I would feel no
guilt about that whatsoever no
compunction no hesitation you cash to
check your users for your family but
here's my fear that the American people
you know we we become accustomed to that
dependence and the effect of these
shutdowns is that society is reordered
and shifted permanently towards greater
government control greater dependence
and so on and there is precedent here I
think precedent points towards this
pessimistic possibility that you know
that people get used to being dependent
on the government there you look at many
different entitlement and Welfare type
programs that were supposed to be
temporary or supposed to be limited and
people just kind of get used to it
either at first there's a there's a
revolt against it people are protesting
people to like it but after a while you
just get used to it it's part of your
reality and I'm afraid that's what
happens here is that people get used to
being dependent on the government
we we get used to this kind of control
we start saying well you know it's not
that bad having the government tell us
when we can leave our house house and
how long we can spend outside and all
these things inside that bad I can do
still do most of the things I want to do
because most of what I want to do is
stay inside and watch TV anyway
I hear this all the time for people
saying what are you complaining about
all the government saying is stay inside
and watch Netflix which of course
there's a lot more to it than that right
especially when you're losing your job
you can't feed your family I mean if
you're looking at the shutdowns there's
nothing but an opportunity to watch
Netflix then that means that you're at a
pretty pretty privileged position a lot
of people it's much more than that but
even if you're in a privileged position
and so most of what you're doing is
watching Netflix it should still bother
you even if all you want to do is watch
Netflix well it should bother you that
that's all you want to do with your life
but it should also bother you that you
can't do other things even if you don't
want to do them so I'm worried that that
attitude takes hold and is this
happening at a point in history where
that is very likely to happen because
we're also dependent on already on our
phones and on entertainment we're
obsessed with entertainment that's most
of what we want to do with our lives
anyway and as long as the government
keeps the bread and circuses going and
they allow us to continue entertaining
ourselves even if we have to do it in
our living rooms now we'll be fine with
whatever else they take from us in terms
of our liberties and freedoms I don't
know but I could see it heading in that
direction and that's what I think we
need to be worried about and that's why
we have to be on guard we have to be
very vigilant okay I want to move on now
actually a little bit earlier than usual
to headlines because some of these are
very important especially the first one
so let's go to headlines and in fact
before I do that actually I want to tell
you about a new weekly podcast from
speaking of jobs and business and
everything it's a good time to tell you
about a podcast from wonder II called
business Wars now each season digs deep
into some of the greatest corporate
rivalries of all time so you think about
Facebook for snapchat or Nike versus
Adidas now if you're if you're like a
really if you're an old-school guy like
myself you would say rather than
Facebook for snapchat the one you're
thinking of is Facebook first myspace
back in the old days on each episode we
give you an inside look at what inspired
entrepreneurs to take risks that drove
their companies to new heights or into
the ground make sure to subscribe to
business wars and other great podcasts
from Wonder
on Apple podcast Spotify or wherever
you're listening right now okay on to
headlines the new unemployment claims
are out we're looking at 6.6 million new
claims last week the final number for
the week before that I think originally
they said it was about six and a half
million or something but the week before
that turns out is 7 1/2 million so
before that it was 3 million so we've
lost give or take 17 million jobs in 3
weeks and I always have to remind
everyone these are just the people who
could and did successfully apply for
benefits many millions of people either
didn't qualify or were not able to apply
because the websites are crashing all
over the country then you have this
influx of people millions people all at
once trying to go on these websites and
apply for unemployment lots of people
don't get through so 17 million is the
tip of the proverbial iceberg let's put
some perspective on this 17 million jobs
lost is more than we lost in the Great
Recession in 18 months
18 months of the Great Recession we lost
we lost fewer jobs than we lost just now
in three weeks the shutdowns have killed
more jobs better way of putting it the
shutdowns have killed more jobs in three
weeks than the Great Recession killed in
18 months we have lost 10% of our
workforce in three weeks okay
the worst unemployment rate we have ever
seen or at least that we've seen the
last say 30 years up to this point was
about 10% our unemployment rate for just
the past three weeks is 10% overall it's
like 13 or 14 percent and again that's
only the beginning that's only the tip
of the iceberg now everybody loves to
seem everyone seems to love projections
these days
so let's project this out we've lost 17
million jobs in three weeks for an
average of five and a half million a
week the White House says now that this
could go on for another eight weeks four
to eight weeks they're saying or longer
so eight times 5.5 million plus the 17
million we've already lost
we're looking at around 66d million
unemployed people by the end of this if
it ends in 8 weeks let's say we could be
looking at something like 60 million
unemployed people and that is a
conservative estimate because that
assumes that the rate won't continue to
climb week over week which there's a
very good chance that it does
conservative estimates 60 million which
would be about a third of the workforce
and that's that's basically the death of
the country
barring as I said a massive great
cultural reawakening and and a change in
our culture that is that is just
absolutely revolutionary that will allow
us the clock to climb back from this but
it won't be easy and it's not going to
just snap back into place as people
there are so many deluded people who
seem to think that's what's gonna happen
that after all this is over
things are gonna just magically go back
to normal that we could lose like 60
million jobs in the span of a month or
two and then it's like nothing ever
happened once
the government says oh okay you can go
back to work and just like that
everything's back to them that seems to
be what people are expecting it's not
going to be that
and and let's let's also remember that
when we talk about jobs being lost these
are not just jobs this we're talking
about livelihood so another way of
putting it is 17 million people have
lost their livelihood in the last three
weeks it's not just a job it's not just
money
this is livelihood this is food on the
table these are you know kids being
clothed and sheltered that's that's what
this represents number two a little hope
in these times and it's looking like our
alien overlords may finally be gearing
up to come and destroy us
fingers crossed God willing can't happen
sue it soon enough here's a video that's
gone viral on YouTube and I don't know
who put it we don't know who put it up
theirs is is it from a YouTube channel
weathers there's just one video and this
is it it's an anonymous person to put it
up there so you know it's very credible
and it supposedly shows some very
interesting activity on the moon watch
this clip
now before we talk about that clip I
wanted to tell you about I want to take
a second here to tell you about LifeLock
you know there are some people who seem
like they're prepared for anything and
these days you know whether it's an
alien invasion like what we're talking
about now but you know these days you do
have to be prepared for anything and
especially especially as you know as
what we're looking at what's happening
in our society now but the truth is that
many people who are usually prepared and
who work and who worry about identity
theft only monitor their credit which
isn't enough that I know for me for a
long time that's the way I was looking
at it that if you want to be prepared
and if you want to you know guard
against identity theft the main thing
you're looking at is your credit or
maybe just your bank account or whatever
but there's a lot more to than that so
you may not be as prepared as you think
you are if if that's all you're looking
at identity breaches seem like they're
happening more these days and with your
breached information like your name
social security number and more
criminals can commit identity theft you
know that's why LifeLock sees more
threats like someone taking out a payday
loan in your name stuff like that that
you might not have any way of knowing
about if not for life lock and then
they're gonna alert you to the possible
suspicious activity and if you end up
having an identity theft issue you'll
have a dedicated identity restoration
specialist who's just a phone call away
and so they're protecting you and then
if the worst case does happen they're
gonna be there to help you out no one
can prevent all identity theft or
monitor all transactions of all
businesses of course but with breaches
on the rise doesn't it make sense to be
prepared this is all we're talking about
is basic preparation and there's really
no reason not to do it especially when
you think about the fact that you can
join LifeLock today and save up a 25%
off your first year go to LifeLock comm
slash walls that's LifeLock comm slash
Walsh to save 25% off okay so I just
played the clip of the the aliens there
it does look pretty pretty pretty into
her pretty convincing of course when you
think about the scale and how quickly
the ships moved over that surface area
and how large they were in comparison to
the surface from our perspective those
would have to be ships that are like 10
miles long and and and moving probably
thousands of miles an hour
so if this is real this is Independence
Day remember Independence Day that
there's a citywide ships that hovered
over the city and then destroyed the
city that's what this is if it's real
the other possibility serious talking to
me again the other possibility is is
that of course it's fake so I mean
what's more likely that someone came up
with a fake YouTube video or that aliens
are about to invade and destroy mankind
you know I think it's kind of 50/50
number three the chief health officer at
the Association of American Medical
Colleges dr. Janice Orlowski spoke to a
political political podcast I should say
this week and this is what you said
quoting from her she said I believe that
we're going to return to a semi-normal
life at the end of May
Memorial Day but the other thing that I
would say is that we have to prepare
ourselves to go through a similar
exercise in the fall if you take a look
at the 1918 1919 influenza pandemic if
you take a look at how coronavirus is
acting this is not just the winter in
spring of 2020 probably late November by
December we are going to go through this
again
and with this is something we've heard
repeatedly that we could have to do this
all over again so okay we you know we we
shed 60 million jobs over the course of
a couple months and then we would try to
reclaim the economy and then in the fall
we do it all over again
so hey just a 60 million jobs here there
no reason why we can't do that before we
go any further I want to tell you about
our good friends over Rock auto comm you
know if you're having car trouble right
now I think rockauto.com is a godsend
for obvious reasons you don't have to
leave your house you just pull out your
phone you go on your laptop and you can
order whatever parts you need and even
if it wasn't for the things happening in
the country right now it would still be
a godsend to have rockauto.com so much
easier than walking into a store having
someone demand answers and information
about your car you might not know off
the top of your head and then when they
don't have what you're looking for which
inevitably is usually the case they end
up going and just ordering it online
anyway which you could have done cut out
the middleman save some money the
rockauto.com catalog is unique and
ARCA bleah easy-to-navigate rockauto.com
has everything from engine control
modules to brake parts tail lamps motor
oil everything you could possibly need
for your car it's right there
rockauto.com always offers the lowest
price as possible rather than changing
prices based on what the market will
bear let me give you an example just
random example totally out of nowhere I
definitely found this completely on my
own based on my own knowledge the
Adelphi FG one four five six fuel pump
assembly for a 2005 2010 honda odyssey
you know that's gonna be three under
fifty three bucks at advance but it's
gonna be two hundred sixteen dollars
rockauto.com and i definitely know what
i just read right there because i'm a
car expert myself but you don't have to
be a car expert to use rockauto.com it's
a family business by the way serving
auto parts customers for 20 years go to
rockauto.com right now see all the parts
available for your car truck right walsh
in there how did you hear about us box
so that they know that I sent you number
four during the white house coronavirus
briefing yesterday a reporter had an
arguably off-topic question but one that
is still of pressing importance one of
the biggest rating hits of the
coronaviruses aside from these briefings
has been a show on netflix called a
tiger king yep and the man who's the
store at this is a former zoo owner
who's serving a 22-year prison sentence
he's asking you for a pardon saying he
was unfairly convicted your son
yesterday jokingly said that you know he
was going to advocate for it and I was
wondering if you've seen showing if you
have any thoughts on pardoning the son
must be done I had a feeling it was time
is that what he said I don't know I know
nothing about it his 22 years for what
what did he do allegedly hired someone
to murder an animal rights activists but
he said that he didn't do that and he
was do you think he didn't do it are you
on his side are you are you recommending
a pardon reporter you're not allowed to
do that you'd be criticized by these
would you recommend a pardon
I'm not weighing it on I don't think you
wouldn't I don't think you would go
ahead you have a question I'll take a
look is that your exotic that's Joe
exciting
can I just say I'm glad that the
reporter asked this question obviously
in the middle of a global
and the oncoming great depression this
is the kind you have a chance to ask the
leader of the free world a question
about all of this to ask him about a
reality TV show makes a lot of sense I
wouldn't criticize that but I would just
caution everybody if you watch Tiger
King which is a fascinating show but I
we call it a documentary not really a
documentary though it's a reality show
emphasis more on show than reality so if
you watch this and you think that Joe
xotic is innocent he must be innocent
let's free him
no he's almost certainly guilty as hell
but you you you can you could tell that
even just in the show but you can't
trust these shows as I've said before
making a murderer people watch that and
and went away from it assuming that
Steven Avery Avery and the other guy
Brendon whatever his name was dasi they
innocent innocent little flowers and of
course you read the court documents and
you discover that no these are psychotic
mess well these are psychotic murderous
freaks and Joe exotic maybe didn't kill
anyone he did kill some Tigers it seems
like maybe they didn't actually succeed
in killing any people but I'm guessing
he's probably guilty but you can't you
can't make these kinds of judgments
based on a Netflix show that's all I'm
trying to say
number five finally Tucker Carlson last
night on Fox had some had some thoughts
on Joe Biden and I enjoyed this segment
watch this Joe Biden is now the
presumptive Democratic nominee nobody
really chose Biden for this job he wound
up in it by a series of defaults and it
shows ask yourself is Joe Biden ready to
lead this country could he find his car
in a three-tiered parking garage could
he navigate a salad bar and by the way
what exactly is his position on the
corona virus pandemic those are the
mysteries Democrats now face button has
been virtually invisible for last month
that's not an accident Joe Biden on
camera means more moments like this we
cannot let this we've never allowed any
crisis from the Civil War straight
through to the pandemic is 17 all the
way around 16 we have never
never let our democracy sakes second
fiddle way that we can both have a
democracy and elections and at the same
time corrective public health you follow
that correct the public health it's hard
to imagine a man like that making it
through a presidential debate or even
staying awake through the inaugural
proceedings it seems likely that at some
point Democratic leaders will try to
find a way to replace Biden before the
November election Andrew Cuomo is the
obvious replacement but there are many
others whatever happens it's worth
taking Joe Biden seriously for this
moment now that he is officially in a
sense the nominee yeah that about sums
it up I think many people are predicting
that they're gonna try to dump Biden at
the convention replace them with
somebody else I would still say the
smart money is on that not happening
just because those sorts of things don't
happen they they're those sorts of
things are talked about and predicted to
happen much more than they actually do
happen if you recall 2016 a lot of
people were saying that was gonna happen
with with with Trump and of course it
did but at the same time this is a
potentially unprecedented situation
where you've got a guy major Party
nominee who is literally losing his mind
and ands and clearly has dementia
so unprecedent such unprecedented
situation does it lead to an
unprecedented result I think that's
that's quite possible but you also have
to keep in mind I mean you look at Joe
Biden's supporters one of the reasons
why Joe Biden is the nominee now and
Bernie Sanders is not is that Joe Biden
had has a lot of support in you know
among minorities so is that something
your Democrat party's gonna want to do
you're gonna you know erase these votes
not just any votes but especially the
votes of your minority base they're
gonna erase those votes and just put
some you're gonna say to those voters no
no no you you didn't know what you were
doing you yeah that he wasn't the right
guy well what will tell you who the
nominee is gonna be now the party does
have the power to do that but I'm not
sure they're gonna want to let's move on
to your daily cancellation and
as a Catholic I'm afraid I'm sorry that
I have to do this but I do have to
cancel the Pope Pope Francis and and
I'll tell you why in fact I'll read now
from the New York Post says Pope Francis
like in the corona virus pandemic two
recent fires and floods as one of
nature's responses to the world's
ambivalence to climate change the Pope
said an interview published Wednesday in
the tablet which is a uk-based Catholic
weekly weekly this is an expression in
Spanish God always forgives we forgive
sometimes but nature never forgives the
Pope was responding to whether he
believed coronavirus could spur
ecological conversion the idea for
people to lead more environmentally
conscious lives through the
understanding that the natural world is
a creation of God Pope Francis said the
the world had yet to respond to recent
partial catastrophes related to the
climate and so he's the Pope went on to
say he believed the co19 outbreak that
has ravaged the globe could inspire
change this is a time to take the
decisive step to move forward from using
a misusing nature to contemplating it
well of course this pandemic has I'm no
scientist but I think I could say that
this epidemic has absolutely nothing to
do with climate change whatsoever and in
fact in many cases we don't know if this
is gonna be the case with this virus but
in many cases the viruses do much worse
in warmer temperatures so if anything
global warming is helping us it could be
a lot worse if we didn't have global
warming who knows so there's no
connection there at all but the main
thing that annoys me here it's not just
the silly attempt to connect the corona
virus to climate change because we know
that the the climate alarmists of which
the Pope is one of them they try to
connect everything they can to climate
change they would they would connect
traffic fatalities to climb in fact I'm
sure they probably have done that if you
look it up they would try to connect
anything they can but the thing that
annoys me just from a theological
perspective you know it's it's true of
course it should it's very possible to
make the point that Christian
should respect nature and should refrain
from gratuitously
defiling nature and polluting and
abusing God's creation that's a it's a
very easy case to make it's true it's
it's a it's an important point to make
although I think most you know most
people probably would agree so I don't
know how necessary it is to say but sure
you could say that and most of us would
agree but you don't need to get into the
climate alarmism and treating that like
it's own religion of sorts there's no
reason for that you don't need to be is
the point you don't need to be a climate
alarmists as a Christian in order to
respect God's creation it's not
necessary but this is the message you
get from some Christians including the
Pope and that's why he is cancelled
alright let's let's up move on to emails
and we talked yesterday about by the way
you can email the show if you become a
Billy why I remember you can email the
mailbag that way so I've got one email
this is a why I'm wrong email and this
is representative of many other emails I
got making a similar point this is from
Ryan says dear Matt you were way wrong
about everything you said about the
cosmological argument I appreciate that
you're trying to play devil's advocate
and poke holes and an argument you agree
with I think Thea should be doing that
much more often iron sharpens iron etc
but you botched it big time you said the
cosmological argument is not the best
argument because it isn't persuasive to
atheists but that doesn't mean it's not
the best argument an argument is good or
the best if it is logically sound if
others are too dumb or biased to be
persuaded by a logically sound argument
that doesn't change the fact that it is
a logically sound argument now on to the
argument itself
you said the cosmological argument
states that everything has a cause but
that is not what the cosmological
argument states the argument goes like
this one everything that begins to exist
has a cause - the universe began to
exist 3 therefore the universe has a
cause this is the cosmological argument
and I don't know if it's the ultimate
best argument but it is certainly very
good and sound it pains me to say it
Matt but you were wrong okay your rights
Ryan that an argument and arguments
failure to persuade doesn't necessarily
mean that it's bad I should have I
should have should have said that the
cosmological argument its failure to
persuade means that it's a less
effective argument or one of the less
effective arguments I think it's pretty
clear in the context that that's what I
meant but you but you but you are right
I saw on that you got me
it is possible especially these days to
make a very good argument to someone and
yet not have it persuade them because
they're just sort of stupid or they're
not paying attention then it happens to
me all the time it's one of my great
frustrations in life because I know if I
make an argument and someone's not
persuaded it must be because they're
stupid it couldn't possibly be PP
because my argument was bad as for the
argument there are many different
cosmological arguments by the way if you
weren't watching the show yesterday this
the reason this came up is someone
emailed and asked what what are the best
in my opinion what are the best and
worst arguments for the existence of God
and you know I said the arguments that I
personally find to be the most
persuasive though I am biased so it's
hard to judge but the arguments I like
arguments like the argument from
morality the argument from consciousness
the argument from the origins of life
the argument from the fine-tuning
argument I think those are good
arguments now I said that I actually
think that the cosmological argument
argued first cause type arguments are
not good and I know that I am very much
in a minority among Christians and
theists in general and saying that
because almost every Christian or theist
I've ever talked to would point to this
as one of the best if not the best
argument I tend to disagree with that
and I tried to explain why okay so back
to the points being made here as for the
argument it's up you know there are many
different cosmological arguments the one
that was cited there in the email the
one you cited an email is the Kalam
cosmological argument I was responding
to the claim that everything must have a
beginning or a cause which is an
argument that I've heard theists put
forward many times
I hear I hear this all the time in fact
and I was just trying to point out that
it's a bad argument because when you say
God began or God caused the argument it
leaves you susceptible to the retort of
well who made God because you just said
everything has to have a beginning he's
he's part of everything isn't he
if everything must have a beginning then
that must include God but if God doesn't
have to have a beginning then that
concedes that it's possible at least for
something not to have a beginning which
means that it's possible for the
universe not to have a beginning you
know it's at least logically possible
even if it's not plausible now I know
the response to that is to say that God
is outside of time and space and it's
God is not a physical entity whereas the
universe is in time and it is physical
and thus mess must have a beginning but
I don't I don't think it's actually true
that logically or scientifically
everything that is quote in time must
necessarily have a beginning I don't I
just I think that that's not true that
strikes me as a ball desertion and
nothing more and it also doesn't make
much sense to say the universe is in
time you know I I hear this all the time
and I don't really know what it means
because first of all time is relative so
to say that the universe is in it is a
bit confusing I don't know that that
actually makes sense as a statement
maybe it does not sure that it does also
it could be circular to say that God is
allowed to have no beginning because
he's out time outside time and space the
response to that from an atheist could
easily be how do you know that God is
outside time and space how do you know
that it's even possible for something to
be outside of time and space and if your
response to that is he has to be outside
it because he made it that's circular
God is outside time and space because he
made time in space and the way that we
know he's outside time and space is that
he made it you know it's just it's a
it's a kind of a circular argument but
let's move on to the Kalam cosmological
cosmological argument I I the the
problem with that argument is that the
first two premises aren't necessarily
true and the
doesn't actually prove that God exists
so we've got a nearly irrelevant
conclusion built on two faulty premises
so that's why I think it's actually a
very bad argument premise 1 everything
that begins to exist has a cause well
maybe but we don't actually know if
that's true or not I think it's true but
doesn't matter what I think it matters
what you can prove and you can't prove
that I think most modern scientists
quantum physicists and so forth would
tell you that the laws of cause and
effect aren't necessarily as clear as we
might think when you get down to the
quantum level and and and when you go
back to the singularity and then before
that the laws of physics as we know them
break down so you can't really make
claims based on them you see so that
that premise I think is dubious premise
2 the universe began to exist well even
if premise 1 is conceded premise 2 kills
the whole thing because that is a
statement of fact the universe began to
exist when we actually don't know that
it is effect remember you can't bring
theological assumptions into this
argument and that's what I was talking
about yesterday the cosmological
argument can seem very persuasive to you
and me because of the theological
assumptions that we bring to it and
those are theological assumptions that I
share that the universe began to exist
but the reason why I think that the
universe began to exist that's not
really because of the Big Bang because
as I'll say is I'll talk about in a
minute the Big Bang itself doesn't prove
that the universe began to exist the
reason I think it and believe it is
because the Bible tells me that the God
created the universe but in terms of
just objective scientific fact what do
we know well we know that the observable
universe
this massive clump of 100 billion
galaxies that we call the universe
began we know that we have no idea what
might be beyond that or what might have
come before it we just have no idea so
you simply can't make that claim well
you can make it but it's just a claim
can't prove it and there are other
logical possibilities now you could say
it seems most plow
Appl that the universe began to exist 14
and 1/2 billion years ago whenever it
was but when you equivocate like that I
think it kind of destroys the argument
anyway it is possible again I say this
from a purely scientific standpoint that
we live in a multiverse that there are
many more and when you think about it's
like we know the universe is 100 billion
galaxies can we really say the universe
is a hundred billion galaxies it
couldn't possibly be any bigger than
that 100 billion galaxies is
incomprehensibly huge already so who
knows maybe it's a quadrillion galaxies
big maybe it's eternally but I don't
know it's possible at the universe is
like an accordion that expands and
contracts eternally it's possible there
are dozens of other possibilities as
well so you that I think that that claim
to the premise cells work and then the
conclusion you know because you say well
it's all you know here the two premises
then we get the conclusion that the
universe has a cause well that even if
even if you get there I mean even if you
can convince someone of the first two
premises which I'm not sure how exactly
you do that because you're gonna need to
come forward with scientific discoveries
that no one you're gonna need to have
some heretofore unknown scientific
discoveries that you're bringing to bear
for that for those premises work but
even if you do the the conclusion only
shows that something caused the universe
it doesn't tell you that that thing is
God you see it doesn't even really get
you close to that because anybody could
could could dream up a million different
logical possibilities of what of what
that thing could be right now William
Lane Craig who first of all is brilliant
and I I'm a huge fan of him I admire and
respect him I think most of his
arguments that he makes are great but
this is the Kalam cosmological argument
is one that he popularized and and on
this one I think it's not good and I
think he kind of pulls a little bit of a
rhetorical bait-and-switch not
intentionally but I think he does
because what he'll try to do if you've
ever heard him explain this argument
he'll try to get from you know the
universe has a cause and then he'll go
immediately from that and say and that
cause must be timeless spaceless
immaterial changeless and and infinitely
powerful and then he'll say and that's
what ever been you know whatever being
is that is God that's what we all mean
when we say God well that doesn't really
work logically does it because yeah
whatever caused it I guess would have to
be immaterial spaceless and timeless
because it is outside of those things
although even there you could dream up
pot you know you could say well what if
the universe is a simulation in some
sort of alien supercomputer I don't
think that's true but it's a logical
possibility that you can't rule out
logically philosophically you can't rule
it out so even that doesn't really work
but let's put the alien simulation thing
aside and let's say okay fine spaceless
time is some material but how you get to
changeless and infinitely powerful
whatever causes a universe of causing
universe doesn't mean that you have to
be changeless and it doesn't even mean
you have to be infinitely powerful it
just means that you have to be the spark
that get that sets off the Big Bang and
then everything sort of takes over from
there
infinitely powerful means that you can
do things like things God can do like
read your mind and answer prayers but
there is nothing about starting a
universe that necessitates being able to
read someone's mind and answer their
prayers for example and that's why ideas
through the centuries have have believed
that the universe was was caused by some
sort of supernatural entity and then
that entity really hasn't done anything
census and maybe isn't able to do
anything else or maybe doesn't even
exist anymore
I don't think that's true but it's it's
it's it's it's there's nothing illogical
about it is my point okay and that's why
I think that that argument is no good
what I and that's why I think we should
focus again on you know argument from
consciousness the moral argument
fine-tuning origin of life I think is a
much better argument than the
cosmological argument because it's built
on as I tried to explain it's built on
premises that are not necess
are not provable and if they're not
provable then they don't really work and
they're also not logically necessary it
seems to me that they either have to be
provable or logically necessary and if
they're neither of those things then you
know you don't get past square one and I
think that's that's the issue but I
enjoy these conversations and I always
enjoy arguing with people that I agree
with it's one of my favorite pastimes
and I think those arguments you know
when you're taught when you're talking
about arguments for the existence of God
I think those discussions are many times
are much more interesting to have with
other people who believe in God because
when you when you when you have that
shared belief and that shared sort of
framework and groundwork you you can
have more detailed and interesting
conversations because you because you
are able to get past square one so I
enjoy that all right we'll leave it
there and also we're not talking about
coronavirus so I was about ten minutes
of Corona free content always nice we're
gonna be off tomorrow for Good Friday
but I hope you have a blessed and and
happy Easter even under these
circumstances especially under these
circumstances and I'll talk to you again
next week god bless and Godspeed
the Matt Walsh show is produced by Sean
Hampton executive producer Jeremy boring
our supervising producers are Mathis
Glover and Robert Sterling our technical
producer is Austin Stevens edited by
Dani D'Amico and our audio is mixed by
Robyn Fenderson the Matt Walsh show is a
daily wire production copyright daily
wire 20 20 hey everybody its Andrew
Clavin host of the Andrew Clavin show
you know some people are depressed
because the American Republic is
collapsing the end of days is
approaching and the moon has turned to
blood but on the Andrew Clavin show
that's where the fun just gets started
so come on over to the Andrew Clavin
show and laugh your way through the
apocalypse with me Andrew Clayton
[Music]